checking with ted now for a full look at
our forecast looking good too for the
weekend denise last weekend of course we
had the
rain we had the mountain snow we had the
wind this weekend though
totally different story right the high
today 65 degrees each day is getting
warmer like we've been telling you about
still though we should be at 68 this
time of the year we'll get there
by the time we get to the weekend 48 for
the overnight low that's a nice chilly
start tomorrow morning again 61 right
now in centennial hills
summer near 55 aliante at 61 degrees 63
downtown and north las vegas
the east side coming in double sixes as
well and we're at 66 for the green
valley
and also henderson 61 rhodes ranch
mountains edge you're coming in at 64
degrees at this hour
61 currently for prop just shy of 60 for
boulder city
and nice and mild in laughlin you're at
68 right now here's our doppler network
again still dry
some clouds we threw in there in the
satellite you see some clouds just sort
of heading down to the south we had
clouds this morning they cleared by
midday like we told you they would
we weren't going to get any precip from
it but we are seeing plenty of that rain
though
in the pacific northwest with also snow
in the cascades this system will dive
down now will this
affect us earlier this week we thought
it would give us a chance for some
showers and some
breezy winds right now looks like all
that energy is going to stay to the
north of the state
also into idaho and all we're going to
get is some light breezes for tomorrow
in the afternoon
but we're eyeing next week later on next
week where we could get some chances
around the region again still too early
to tell what that's going to do because
the forecast could change in just two
days but we'll keep our eye on that for
next week right now it just looks like
maybe some mountain snow
temperature trend though for the week
ahead like we said the weekend looking
good there's your weekend right near
average finally
complete 180 from last weekend we had
all that cold weather in the snow
the mountains and then look at next week
temperatures will get
close to records probably not going to
reach them but get close on monday
wednesday and thursday in those mid to
high
70s it's december or november right
feels way warmer than average with those
numbers you see for next week 45 degrees
overnight
chilly and mostly clear your winds again
staying light
light breezes for tomorrow to pick up
just a little bit but not much sunny and
milder
67 degrees for tomorrow that puts us
near average
meanwhile your temperatures for the week
ahead like we talked about your weekend
looking good in those mid to high 60s
a great looking weekend and then next
week there we go
close to those regular numbers like we
talked about additional cloud cover by
wednesday
but otherwise looks like we'll still
stay on the dry side
that's your most accurate forecast back
to you